as the disease spreads to more of
China's provinces the leadership has
issued an unequivocal order to all
officials be honest and transparent that
now includes the media state TVs
devoting more coverage to the
containment measures in Wuhan where the
outbreak began three weeks ago
Medical Teams have been instructed to
intensify their efforts after a warning
the virus could mutate and expand we
advise everyone not to go to Wuhan and
we advise Wuhan residents not to leave
the city unless their special
circumstances this will help reduce the
flow of people and the risk of
transmission but the flow of people to
China goes on at Kowloon West train
station in Hong Kong most passengers
were heeding the advice to wear face
masks in crowded places there are two
direct trains a day from here to Wuhan
on Tuesday many passengers were
canceling trips and seeking refunds
hiah hiah I was supposed to be going to
Wuhan I had not been back for 15 years
now there is this big disease and my
aunt told me not to come I think it's
pretty serious
I'm worried about the huge crowds on the
transport system and a possible big
outbreak of the virus this is the
suspected source of the virus a
wholesale seafood market in Wuhan media
reports say it sold a variety of wild
meat under new measures announced on
Wednesday the trade in such meat as well
as live poultry is now banned the
majority of those who've died so far had
underlying illnesses and most were
elderly and of course this is really the
last thing the Hong Kong government
needs right now for the past few months
it's been completely preoccupied with
the ongoing political protests now it's
having to deal with this outbreak of a
new virus which could be on the scale of
SARS the Hong Kong chief executive Kara
Lam is currently in Davos attending that
economic forum and of course she'll be
trying to talk up her government's
efforts to try to contain the virus here
in Hong Kong as well as talking up Hong
Kong
economic prospects as to what China does
next well President Xi Jingping
has made clear that the safety of the
Chinese people is paramount right now so
that could mean he's prepared to take
some tough decisions perhaps shutting
down part of the transport network in
China and shutting down more areas in
China that have been infected by this
disease but of course it's all happening
a Chinese New Year with up to 400
million people now on the move all right
Adrian thank you for that update from
Hong Kong